this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it is time to kick off the what if
season 2 journey joined here with the
man the myth the legend the koi the JRE
how you doing buddy holidays are here
and so is what if I am so excited to be
covering this with you John is not with
us I promised him earlier this year that
he would have a little bit time off from
filming and this is allowing us to uh do
a couple of thinks that way he could
have the holidays you know Greg and Koy
don't get time off we don't get from the
filming we must be on camera at all
times guys you know what to do please go
ahead leave a like on this video that
would be extremely appreciated also be
sure to subscribe click the notification
Bell cuz Coy and I are going to be
covering all of what F season dose and
thank you to prepper for helping us set
it down these highlights lastly massive
thank you to all who have joined us at
our patreon page over there you get the
full length reat watch along where you
sync up with your own copy of what if
and John and I cover several things
exclusiv with highlights and watch
alongs included Coy you ready so ready
let's do
it
ominous ooh cool Blade Runner Blade
Runner Vib immediate Blade
Runner oh wow really Blade Runner to
xandor xandor a place where everyone's
luck eventually runs out oh is this the
nebula episode must be
even
yand oh sweet it looks great someone did
this to him obviously yes didn't do it
to himself the question
is why no damn it come on gra there's
only five things in could have G
nebula you can step away from the body
the real cops are here damn novacore oh
she's part of the novacore oh yeah yeah
she got the chest P she's like yeah
already cracked the case huh I don't
need black ordered trash telling me how
to do my job former black order I earn
my stars here same as you she's got a
perfect Noir voice for this character
type is there a problem Corman this is
xandor all we got are problems yes the
Dark Side of
xandor wow they straight up just said
we're going to do Blade Runner what if
we did Blade Runner with nebula okay I'm
down
time
space
reality it's more than a man path Howard
the Duck is coming he's got to be here
ta came back for this and Ponder the
question why what is damn it who
is so close in this universe Ronin the
accuser betrayed Thanos oh cool Titan's
thirst for power had met its match and
in his fall he took nebula's Sister
Sister along with him so alternate
ending for Guardians of the Galaxy in a
way yeah if he' succeeded a drift in the
ruins of my past until someone saw the
light in
me I really love the music in this
episode so far compassion and kindness
is that Glen Close did they get Clen
close come back in voice take my hand
yes I swore the novacore oath seek the
light be the light never St from his
that's cool I like this she always
needed something to belong to yeah she's
isolated her whole life so finding a
family Ronan and his forces attacked
bringing zandar to the verge of
Destruction he became Thanos yeah
effectively fire up the shield generator
she locked down xandar behind an
impenetrable planetary Shield like Iron
Man wanted to xandar was saved for the
time
being but at what cost I find this more
effective than the planet that was
destroyed in the Marvel I'm just saying
immediately
immediately 5 years in isolation has
brought out the worst in all of us still
hope or no hope I took an oath I'm not
going to lie I'm really digging this Coy
yeah this blun isting sci-fi film new
art it's pretty awesome also it feels
like what Marvel was doing phase one of
making it specific GTH and Saul wasted
their time hunting for the Killer's
weapon when they really should have been
looking for the victims yandu and I had
a past and some memories to go with it
where's the whistle
Arrow you and I make quite the
team huh
yeah you and I nebie we make fight the
team it's like Star Wars guys oh it's
R2D2 but it's summoning the arrow I
think it's going to get it to come back
through that whistle there we
go awesome that's cool to utilize her
skill sets that we know and turn her
into a detective Ive yeah and her voice
is so Noir
based whoa oh yandu what did you get
into yandu was trying to do something
good there are no records of these
schematics in any archive on zandar not
even on the shadow Network negative
thank you for your inquiry the bleakness
actually feels palpable and the weight
in the animated characters feels I don't
know I connect more definitely Xander's
on the brink yandu got himself caught up
with some dark Forces On The Rise xandar
only has until dawn I did find something
at the crime scene but it seems yandu
gave his life to protect it do you trust
her Glenn Close yeah never she hunts
Dalmations
Greg you have a
warrant yeah Blood Rave it's cool to
turn it into a cyber Punk world like I
like xandar going dark it's a really
interesting take of the whole thing it
yeah there's got to be Easter eggs here
reference Howard the coming must be
point out Groot Groot where's
Howard is that Drax
yeah
hey rollers table but feir warning he
does not like to be buzzed when he's on
a hot streak is Howard the Duck the one
in I hope he's the High Roller so bad
Hey
Howard
yes I'm running a casino things are
great and speaking of great waitress
could you bring us some small bites for
the reflective woman over here or do you
just eat
megabytes I love how much his character
has evolved in the MCU too Howard the
Ducks actually got a great world if you
have this Arrow I'm guessing yandu
finally turned a paler shade of
blue he gave his life to protect this I
ran these schematics through every
archive on xandar but nothing could I do
them
what is it that's what I asked you're
the detective that's why I'm
ask this is a really good back and forth
that's an old Citywide Mainframe core
it's a unit b42 I believe I didn't think
there were many of those left how the
hell would you know that I know all
sorts of things I'm more than just a
pretty face you
know what's in it sanitation department
metadata unpaid parking tickets Rush
Hour statistics even an actual kitchen
sink go back one unpaid parking tickets
not that Rush our
statistics source code for the shield
generator looks like someone might be
trying to take down the planetary Shield
if this episode is a testament to what
the rest of the season
is I need to get into that main frame
and destroy those codes places like that
not everyone who goes in out many of the
people who enter these premises end up
dead tiger loves play corg so much I can
see him staying but not to direct no oh
yeah absolutely no matter where it takes
me oh cool nor fade I'd need someone
with a rep for breaching highend
security someone who' infil zarian
systems before it' be cool if she te up
with him outside of Guardians Corman
nebula y
Rog ah Jud
law so you know me no mus no fuss I'd
watch this show a this show nebula yes
nula is great I need someone who knows
their way around xandarian security and
you thought of me I arrested you for it
didn't I but if you'd rather stay here
I'm open to other recommendations this
feels like animatrix it does that's
exactly what it feels like containment
in D repeat
containment like it's actually building
the World by building a new world I love
it yeah there's like real composition
and a distinct style to this episode
yeah it's directed give me some
credit just like in Guardians when they
did the the breakout and now they're
using this clever
Ploy a sweet I love these yeah Matt Reef
shots score again
great if what if becomes one of my
favorite phase five I know right unheard
of you took an oath and this is what it
takes to keep it can't say it looks like
that from where I'm sitting oh I don't
need you to understand I just need you
to live up to your reputation she's like
a combination of Harrison Ford and Ryan
Gosling from blade runers which is what
I want in nebula Noir you do realize I
don't have any tools with
me man blade 249 great editing 2200
stories that's a long way down I didn't
break you out of jail to point out the
obvious it doesn't need to take all
night
cool he knew that it's like it's it's
like the Multiverse why did you stop
Live Wire little early in the night to
fry your circuits don't you think yo
nebula's hot in this episode love that
got got to admit man a jesica rabbit
kind of way core overheating oh was that
your clever plan give me some credit I
hope you like working underwater that's
how it's going to cool the court well I
I like how nonreactive nebula is like
normally she just gets like Teen Angst
angry a lot and here she's just she has
that coldness about her that I how we
met her and there's a little more
confidence I like it a lot I think
empathy caused her to waver her
confidence which is she doesn't have yet
like she's part of a team but she's not
like soft she's normally more seething
at the teeth and rage and so I like this
portrayal a lot actually of her San main
frame corol impressive the architect
with thanos's gone you wouldn't have as
much be rage about so it's interesting
that Arc how that would go Omega class
cybernetic organism detected you should
follow your advice compatibility
approved Jack in Neo the animatrix
commence connection connection sequence
bad
ass whoa lawn mower man she's
downloading the whole
thing well I like how that warp shot
happened oh that's so cool source files
deleted now it's all up there Jesus God
actually I think I can put that source
code to better you you son of a oh
no you've gotone soft log out sequence
stalled system compromised system
overheating oh no they're going to kill
her off you don't have to worry about
xandar anymore Ronin has big plans for
it come on
nebula now she won't overheat oh she
going go back to her
rage but no no it it was just red
because of the computer system she took
rage not cuz she's evil that helped us
visually I absolutely love it it feels
like an anime
character whoa does she need to breathe
Glen Close Glen Close betrayed it's you
I knew that blast wouldn't kill her she
always has been a Survivor she kills
dations this was all a setup all so you
could start an invasion yeah there's
just no shame in surrender and what else
Ronin promised to keep me in charge in
exchange for my cooperation greed is
evil you've been using me this whole
time you're a machine what did you
expect fight back finish her and make
sure you melt down the pieces when
you're done yes ma'am oh what a cruel
way I hate when people talk about nebula
like that what a waste down
yeah yeah come on
nebula get up nebula
good get
him
damn man the expression they've brought
this time around to finish this
yes oh I love the lines too very very
anime
yeah it's very anime I'm calling it boys
colan nebula End of Watch End of
Watch I got to say especially firing and
especially compared to the last season
this actually looks like comic book
panels you know like the framing of it
it doesn't just look like a cartoon show
this this actually looks like a comic
book which adds to that
anime oh my God damn that one eye
Terminator
look oh oh she's getting back in tune
with the r paper but it's uncuttable
paper cuz it's made of
rock
amazing
stupid say I told you so but your head's
bashed in so you wouldn't remember I'm
fine I just need a drink and
guns I don't even think we could Pawn
you for party I said I'm fine
oh jackpot this is bad those aren't
supposed to pay
out more Howard the Duck Season five of
Marvel you see an elium I have it's a
little bit like that but the planet the
rich the poor Moon There She is welcome
back to the land of the living there was
a thck in there where I was thinking
what am I going to sing at her
funeral about those guns you know
military grade sure to kill which I'm
not saying I
do
it's my favorite hour of the
duck killing it the people of xandar are
going to suffer drink more Nova Prime
will take your liquor don't drink more
no rock paper
[Laughter]
scissors just the delivery energy of
Howard the Duck and her straightforward
Cadence so fun and then rock paper
scissors is is genius
yeah oh did not see that look at that
Guardian
team why is this episode so good Howard
with the comic accurate Howard with the
bandana if this was an apparent cor and
I did not have the highest expectations
was not excited for this in the least I
will admit exceptional The Shield open
by
Dawn was I dreading it a little bit is
it amazing yes it is what the hell oh
yes how is this
all yeah I swear style there's so many
great I've got a
bandana
unbelievable oh great poov nebula Nova
Prime I'm here to end this good choice
in the handheld oh good
catch Ronin is entering the atmosphere
as we speak you can't stop this but it's
not too late to join me no I think it is
Shields closing this shows the
importance of strong visuals because
that communicates so much emotion that
you could do it in an efficient amount
of time and they've rebuilt in a whole
team in 20 minutes and made us care
about them it's taking the ships down
with
it and improved Howard the Duck
10-fold oh she's cutting him in half you
trible crossed me Triple Crossed
actually I saw yon rocks move a mile
away so I put my little twist on the
code oh that's clever the moment you
told me to solve this by any means
necessary I knew you'd broken our oath
still doesn't make it hurt any less
n it's over Nova Prime I'm taking you in
all of you we'll see about that love how
yr's a again he's always that guy
except she was smart enough to see the
twist that the Marvels tried to make
[Music]
special
whoa you broke the a I don't think it'd
be that easy to break my first nebula
was so Glen Close to killing her so Glen
Close aren't you a big deal Betty
no
that's yeah oh yeah puny bdy some Hulk
smashing a this is so
[Music]
cool I feel like xandar actually has a
personality
yeah great shot god
damn yeah she's going to survive a bit
more than you there Glen Close take my
hand why could you just join me I took
an oath you ruined
everything
dumbass cool
awesome oh my God and now they can open
the doors let the I mean I just pray to
God we don't get a bunch of idiots say
woke culture hey that's a woman
in power which can't happen it can't if
you keep the path Nova you can find your
way to the light well well if it isn't
the
Supernova you blew up our Space Invaders
thanks to you the planet's actually
getting its life back and your liquor
license is
safe I love how her actual delivery with
people matches her narration internal
narration yeah the Ness of her totally
plays here usually there's a contrast
but I love how it matches so well that
was like Seth Green as Howard the Duck
just Chang game that was so good okay
whoa well listen that made me feel great
I'm much more excited about the rest of
the season now and I'll tell you what
also makes me feel
great are
sponsors thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in Ecommerce so whether you're
launching a passion project are scaling
to new heights Shopify is the e-commerce
Powerhouse guiding you at every step
from creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
thank you again reject Nation from
simplifying sales to scaling our
offerings Shopify has been a Cornerstone
of our success and Shopify isn't just
for us owers 10% of us e-commerce
backing businesses big and small in over
175 countries their award-winning
support always there to guide you so
ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at
shopify.com rejects all overc case
shopify.com rejects start your Shopify
success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacted me due to
a suspecting hacking attempt and funny
enough I realized I hadn't actually
activated my expressvpn on my new laptop
that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced
a serious hacking issue on YouTube a
couple years ago that made expressvpn my
go-to for both security and freedom I
mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you
can use expressvpn to watch movies and
shows on Netflix that are not available
in your country this means accessing a
vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your
fingertips it's super easy open
expressvpn switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korea Netflix Hulu
BBC I player YouTube or more expressvpn
has you covered and it's incredibly fast
ensuring no buffering or lack for smooth
HD streaming it's versatile too working
on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means
you can enjoy your favorite shows on
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com Rex to learn more thank
you again all right guys if you're
listening to us on Apple and Spotify we
just watch what if episode one of season
2 now before going into this both Co and
I were like it's what if you know it's
kind of on the lower end of the spectrum
for us when it comes to the rating the
season one like there were some couple
of episodes that we quite loved uh but
overall as a whole and I feel like this
one episode my they already set a new
bar for what the rest of the episodes
have to be uh with this with this
version of nebula I mean we said it
plenty of times during the reaction but
in case you decided just to skip the
reaction which I find very odd is like I
I loved her portrayal of how it
contrasted so differently compared to
what we see her in live action they
actually took it a different direction
it's not just a fun hey what if we like
body swapped or what if we position
swapped we actually made a a different
character out of her that also still
made sense based off the trajectory
where we left off with her at a certain
point in time which is what they did
with Loki this felt like what they did
with Loki yeah exactly and that's what
what ifs are on the comics and that's
why I didn't love the what if season 1
as much because what if season 1 felt
like it was like what if Peter Parker
took trigonometry I was like I don't
care about any of these ws and like it
just didn't like do enough for me and
then like by the end I cared because I
did care about uh sorcerer Supreme I
cared about and then they didn't do
anything with it so I felt like you
finally got me to Care by the end of
what if season one and then they like
ignored it and teased it and then didn't
deliver whereas this is the Loki thing
where it's an actual what if of grabbing
a character we do know and love and then
just twisting them at a point that we've
already lived through exactly exactly
hold on I'm waiting to see really quick
if there's going to be something here at
the
end it would seem not it would seem not
all right it stays in the video us
waiting for a post traumatic pause
that's what the patrons get every day
that's our watching faces well the other
side of it too that I really loved was
like we know of xandar we know of these
places H you know we still call her Glen
Close I don't even remember her
character name Glen but you know you
take an even though you're doing an
alternate version of them they still
feel like they're actually making them
more of a character they still feel like
we're getting more of a personality
behind them and I really liked the
Intrigue of it I mean just overall the
the overall nuances I spent forever
talking about what makes this one
episode better than most of what of
season one just from a season premiere
point of view season premier point of
view directing upgrade animation upgrade
everybody when we did the review of the
trailer everybody was like it's the
exact same animation I was like no it no
it's not no there's so much more
attention to detail and the movement
Style could be the same but like it's
like you can do a sketch or you can do
an art like they went in they kept
adding and then the the DP of this the
the way this is shot the framing all
that stuff the way you introduce the
season is this yeah like I I remember
being kind of okay about the the Peggy
Carter one of season one that was a
Premiere and but that's more of what I
meant of yeah okay it's it's Captain
America but it's Peggy instead yeah
that's what I mean by that's not a what
if comic that's like all right you just
changed
characters not what if that's all you
really did and then here we did a very
different plot which all lowed of cool
Direction and even yonr like the limited
screen time you get here he's still got
more of a distinct personality than he
does in the entirety of Captain Marvel
entirety of Captain Marvel and the twist
actually works better and then calling
out the twist works great because how
obvious The Twist wasn't Captain Marvel
I found myself going it would be really
cool if this version of nebula did
somehow come to the live action yeah I
would love to see this version even her
showing up with the yond do Mohawk and
the ER I didn't see any of that coming
that somehow I didn't either and then
all the great Guardians like you know
comic cover shots it was like it was so
obvious which is what I love when you go
like of course they were setting that up
but I didn't think of it cuz like the
rock paper scissors joke I'm like that's
funny but then they made it the team and
I was like that would be an incredible
team yeah and that's that's the another
thing even looking like a comic book you
know we said during the reaction too is
that this actually felt like I was
looking at a panel I kept comparing it
to you know obvious like sci-fi touches
of anime and it's got cyber Punk World
Blade Runner animatrix animatrix Ghost
in the Shell things that Matrix were
inspired by like all the the derivative
all the the or Boris Matrix in anime
there's reason Blade Runner yeah all
those like wonderful flourishes
throughout but it didn't just feel it
actually inhabited it instead of just
paying homage to it yeah it didn't feel
like it was trying to take the style it
felt like it was in the style of yeah
and they Justified it storywise of how
we got there delivery I never even
considered how nebula would be great in
no Noir such a funny like you know when
like kids are like who' win a fight Hulk
or Thor I've often done that with
characters since phase one of Marvel
where I'm like what genre would I want
to see blankin you know since they had
so many genres I never considered Noir
nebula and it's so obvious and it makes
sense for her to be a detective like
with her skill that's what I mean they
actually just used what her skill set
was they did what if they
exactly they just did oh yeah you know
we could what would be a cool genre it
seemed like an apt genre to to put
insert her into this felt like a phase
two movie where they were like we've
established the characters we're going
to change the genres around we're going
to enhance the characters it it didn't
make you have to relearn them it didn't
do an origin story because of where it
took off and that's why I think phase
two is so strong I like winter soldier
more than First Avenger because now we
already know the characters now you can
try a new genre I like Guardians of the
Galaxy more than I like the First
Avenger movie because as much as I love
The Avengers getting together I was like
these are characters I wouldn't have
expected to love and we're invested this
did that it's a phase two property where
it's like dive in take a pivot make a
genre and be dope oh and what they did
too with I got one criticism and I'll go
into it uh breaking the
arrow but the uh the Whatchamacallit um
uh what were we talking about I
interrupted you had one criticism and I
interrupt like an assho I wasn't that no
that's fine don't worry about the arrow
I was so stressed about how much we have
to film today that like I keep see you
GL at I did not sleep cuz I was like
there's so much to do I can't sleep
that's not healthy um the what what was
it
called Batman and uh I don't remember he
wasn't in it there was something there
this all stays in the video ain't
cutting jack out of this one uh
Glen Close uh Yan Rog uh nebula uh
Howard the Duck um Howard the Duck there
it is Howard the Duck that's what it was
Howard the Duck it's a character who
like started off as a fun little Cameo
and in a post credit green loves him in
real life and ask James gun to play him
okay I didn't know that and as it
progressed where you see a little bit
more of his appearances I was like yeah
it's it's amusing it's amusing but I
kind of feel like the joke's been done
to death of Howard the Duck and here
they actually made him a real character
and in the comics Howard the Duck has a
lot of point it's like though bad
writers don't know how to write squirrel
girl bad writers don't know write Howard
the Duck and they make them punch lines
bad writers don't have to make Deadpool
and they make Deadpool a Punch Line This
is much like that where it's like no no
Howard the Duck actually has a point
like Howard the Duck can be great and
here he is and Seth Green got the
assignment like there's a reason Seth
loves Howard the Duck and this is like
showcasing that it's like a Danny deito
kind of character yes you know and I I
love the portrayal of him it's Joe pesi
and Lethal Weapon yeah yeah yeah it's a
little guy with an attitude that's just
trying to get through cuz the back and
forth too I thought they had a great
like this was paced better than most of
season 1 and the way how they're back
and forth of the dialogue with nebula's
very you know noirish uh dry delivery
and then Howard the duck's very
expression delivery and ta like about
the people around him and then Groot
only did a couple lines because that's
dry like nebula but it added comedy they
really balanced who was on that team
well yeah and when a day and age when
you got like animated properties like
spider-verse inin invincible and then
you know I'm but just speaking speaking
in terms of Aesthetics you know like the
Teenage beut Ninja Turtles animated
movie those films uh have made such an
impact Puss and Boots and that I do
think they needed to up the aesthetic
overall because that there's so much
that can happen in Just Vibe and mood
and emotion based off of how something
thing looks and feels agreed whereas
sometimes these Rush Marvel movies could
stand a benefit from letting their
visual effects artists really go to town
because that could do a lot of work for
you that the writing may not be able to
have the time to dive into just like
this the best thing to happen of what if
season 2 was a strike the animators you
know the animators got prob I I don't
think they wanted to put this out in the
time and I also think that the the
episode that's Christmas is probably
always planned to come out at Christmas
but I do feel like giving this time to
really animate really flourish and so
you said animation aesthetic with those
I was gonna go with spiderverse and
Invincible as being when you trust in a
comic property in an animated medium you
can really really adapt comic books in a
better way even then live action
sometimes because you can like do a
characterization in a more unreal way
this wasn't trying to be photorealistic
this wasn't trying to be it was trying
to be awesome and follow the character's
Journey which is what I think Invincible
does really well and they did here yeah
yeah for sure for sure man for sure my
one criticism that I would say is that
um that
the I I liked what happens to
xandar but there's just something about
the MCU that does not know how to get
Ronin down yeah like he's just not a
presence here no and also the xandar we
felt was a character but we didn't have
any xandarians feel like they were like
changed I would have liked another 2
minutes of like life on xandar under the
you know oppressive Darkness just a
little bit and then maybe you know uh uh
what's his name you just said it um
yandu y yonr yonr uh just like him you
know scheming like I wanted a little bit
more villainy a little bit more you know
that direction but overall like this was
exceptional this is exceptional guys
what did you think about our first
episode of what if leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like thank you to our sponsors let's end
this with a
pat John pick name fev Doren FV you know
what we're going to get you for
Christmas this year we are going to get
you a teleportation device we need that
for you for you specifically so that way
whenever it comes time to us watching
Hunter Hunter we teleport you into our
bathroom office yes so that way and
we're going to lock it so we can you can
hear us through the wall you can hear us
and if we have a question we shout it at
you and whenever you show up in our
bathroom the toilet not
okay yeah sure and the toilet won't be
working honestly didn't catch what John
what' you say I said you better have the
answers because you know calling on him
for you know whatever we need to ask him
about so like I could care less about
that I really just want F trapped in the
bathroom while we're filming Hunter
Hunter I think that'd be hilarious sure
yeah absolutely and none of the
facilities work there's no paper or you
know other uh hygiene products yeah so
don't even think about using that bad
it's not for your wellbeing and so it's
not a practical Choice what we're going
to do then is while you're in the
bathroom you're going to get a Shard
that slides
underneath through the bathroom slant oh
every 10 minutes and you're going to be
like what is you're not going to be able
to tell what this Shard is you're going
to get get little shards at a time then
eventually you're going to put it
together you're going to realize it's a
Blu-ray oh what's this blue it's a
Blu-ray of Hunter Hunter what they're
not even
watching the Blu Ray I gave they're all
in here and he's destroying the Blu-rays
yes feed it to me every time I go to the
bathroom that's your present man is I'm
good to torture you in our bathroom I
give you up yeah that's what you get for
Holiday discs that's what you get for
for all your goodwi and your
encouragement of our watching
experiences take that FL your
preservation CH bu you get locked in a
bathroom to suffer with nothing while
you listen to us have fun not even the
sink works so just sweaty and gross and
I forgot a flush and the mirror is
broken so you can't even look at
yourself to contemplate
Insanity it's just a room you're just a
Sol room man we're going to torture you
in solitary all you hear is Joy
happening outside and us getting Minor
Details wrong that could use more
context only we want to complain are we
going to say it right up against the
bathroom door yeah of what we don't like
about this episode and you promised it
would be amazing and it's a oneway
oneway audio room so you can only hear
us but can't hear you respond can't hear
you man two-way sound sorry about it
buddy but you can't hear you does that
ex I a bathroom that does that why would
I why would I want that for the bathroom
I can hear them but they have
no idea how loud they're
being I me the opposite but same same
Theory where somebody I would hate that
too man Wonder like someone slips and
falls in the shower and I'm like I can't
hear you you devise this so that way
people can hear you but you might
be taking a shower somebody breaks in
you can hear them but they can't hear
that you're taking a shower so you could
sneak one over on
them what John do you have any idea how
dangerous this is you very it's not a
good idea terrible I'm just saying like
does it exist unless there was like a
way like the way you enable it for like
headphones like a noise cancelling one
yeah where you're like oh I enable this
do a noise cancelling bathroom
installment that I could like flick the
switch like that would actually be an
amazing device who would not buy that
make a smart device you got would not
knows how to isolate your voice but can
mix out all of your bathroom sound there
was a way where you could like yeah
where you like turn a switch on that way
you're guest when they have to poop they
may have noise cancelling they don't
have to worry about how loud they're
being or my wife doesn't have to worry
about how loud I'm being not that I give
a crap about how loud I'm being for so
long like put your ear up against this
door you love me no matter
[Laughter]
what I'm going to be abjectly disgusting
no way is this going to be okay if the
rules are reversed I won't even
acknowledge this biological phenomenon
happens to
you but who wouldn't buy that I feel
like a lot of people wouldn't buy but I
would buy it I would spend I would spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars yeah if
you if you had a bathroom that you could
could easily like yeah mute the sound or
yeah again like mix out your bathroom s
so if you need to be on the phone or you
need to like call out the door people
will just hear your voice and nothing
else that's why I love F he keeps his
creative he keeps those creative juices
flowing as he is a has to hold in his
juices from flowing while we watch
Hunter Hunter that's the trade that's
the exchange anyway F Merry Christmas
buddy this is the best show I think
we've done all year yep we were holding
it in to the very
end